yeah a very tragic event indeed Sarah
Jane there were five people on board one
of these Blackhawks four on another the
Blackhawk hh-60 adapted for medical
evacuation and indeed according to the
military there were Medical Teams on
board conducting a planned training
drill by night they were flying we're
told in multi-ship formation essentially
flying together now this happened in the
dark at night the pilots were flying
using night vision goggles the accident
or the incident we're told happened
while they were flying there was the war
taking part in medical evacuation drills
but they weren't conducting those drills
at the time when the aircraft came down
the military says that there was no
indication of any problem on board prior
to the crash happening although they do
say and the phrase they used was that
the pie violence were able to land in a
field across from a residential area
they say that's lucky so that perhaps
indicates that there was some action on
upon the part of the pilots to avoid a
tragedy on a larger scale let's listen
to the Brigadier General from Fort
Campbell home of the 101st Airborne
Division the so-called Screaming Eagles
talking about this incident that
happened at 10 o'clock local time last
night
this was a training progression and
specifically they were flying a
multi-ship formation two ships under
night vision goggles at night it was
five and four and that is fairly typical
there's a pilot a co-pilot a crew chief
and then often you'll have Medics or
other Personnel on the aircraft as well
these specific aircraft were a medical
evacuation aircraft however we believe
that they were the accident occurred
when they were doing Flying not
deliberate medical evacuation drills
there you go the Brigadier generals
speaking that he also said that a
so-called safety team is on the way from
Alabama to investigate the cause of this
accident they will use a black box on
board computer data to Aid them in their
investigation they also want to might
want to take evidence from eyewitnesses
which could inform the investigation
into what happened one local resident
who's well used to seeing Blackhawks fly
over his property he says that typically
they do fly a law but they are two three
minutes apart he speaks of them being
low and flying very close to each other
talking about how they looped round and
then he had a noise and saw what looked
like a firework going off to use his
words currently there is an operation
ongoing to inform the next of kin across
the United States and indeed with
relatives across the world the governor
of Kentucky talking about how this is a
tough tragic day for his state